back here on the Rich Eisen show to talk
about the rules changes that were made
in the NFL yesterday and some that were
withdrawn and some were tabled as the
lead Fox rules analyst for their
football coverage and my good old friend
from back in the day being the head of
NFL refs when he was and I was sitting
on the NFL Network total access that we
always had a great chats as we plan to
have right now Mike Pereira how are you
Mike well I'd say pretty darn good you
know you're still working and I'm
catching beautiful trout in Crain
Prairie reservoir about 35 miles from
Bend Oregon
just living the dream in the dream when
he texted me yesterday saying that you
were gonna be fishing when we spoke and
I'm like hey you sure got a good one I
had a nice uh we had a nice look a shot
of what what appears to be what you're
doing right now that weird that the
reception will be good it sounds like
you're sitting right next to me so we're
all good I am and Leo is just reeling in
his fourth fish I've caught three
already today and it's just it's just
great but I thought football rules can
we do that we can do that and I greatly
appreciate you taking the time to do
exactly that
so can you explain to people what the
difference between withdrawing a
proposal and what tabling a proposal
actually means because the sky judge got
withdrawn and the fourth and 15
alternative to a one shot from fourth
and 15 for 25 alternative to an onside
kick got tabled what does all that mean
Mike well if it's withdrawn then it's
got to be brought up again next year
it's basically dead if it's tabled you
know then they're gonna look at a few
more things and I think rich they
brought up some good points you know as
they try to get you know give teams more
of an opportunity to get the ball back
if they're behind I think that you know
when you look first the issue with the
clock could you just run out the clock
if there was two seconds then they said
that's not right they said okay let's
make it a just a dead ball play so no
time would run off the clock and I think
that was fair but I really do think that
it's too much of an opportunity to come
back because you conceivably could
complete one play that gained you know
40 yards and being a
where you could kick a field goal to win
the game and that that doesn't sound
right that brings back the old issue of
you know the overtime period when you
could get the ball in the first Drive
run a couple plays take a long field
goal win the game so III really think it
needs more more thought I personally
think it needs to be junked period you
know to me you know an onside kick is an
onside kick the opportunities to recover
are slim down in that range of 7% but
hey listen you're behind so you
shouldn't necessarily get a free shot or
have it made easier for you to get to
get the ball back but you know they'll
take a further look at this but whoever
was the tennis said okay wait a minute
not fair not fair you could win the game
on one play when a normal onside kick
the ball is dead as soon as it's
recovered by the kicking team you know
beyond the receivers restraining line so
I think they used good good sense in at
least tabeling that so then what would
be the fix if you can I know you want to
junk it there are others who kind of
like it and by others that would be me I
kind of dig the idea of giving one shot
of seeing an actual football play as
opposed to some sort of a scrum where
somebody makes a boner Hands team play
and then that's the way a game changes I
wouldn't mind seeing an actual football
play so would it be the distance or for
me the issue would be one penalty flag
on the defense gives the offense the
ball based again on what an automatic
first down would come with that play so
then everybody's favorite defensive hold
from fourth and 15 play that gives you
an automatic first down
that's rise you know it's it's you know
there's too many unknowns about the
thing III just you know to me I get a
little worrisome what would be a fix
well I guess you could look at it a fix
and say that the plate could maximum
take you to the 40-yard line that you
you couldn't go beyond that but then
that's unrealistic basically to shut
down
play midstream you know because you get
beyond the 40-yard line but you know we
always try to create excitement which i
think is great you know to me the sky
judge proposal is more important and but
yet you know that one you know to me is
getting a little bit less discussion as
we go forward so let's get to that one
Mike Pereira here on the Rich Eisen show
it's funny when we saw senior technology
advisor being the title that either
somebody who maybe they're the ones who
came up with the wardrobe malfunction
concept the other you know many years
ago to call it I text you I'm like
what's a senior technology advisor you
want to respond what your text was back
to me we want to call it something
different than what the AAF called it
and you want to do a different do it a
different way and when I when I look
back at the AAF guy judged position who
put it together Hall of Famer Bill
Polian
and and I think he did a good job in
discussion with those of us involved in
the league to say let's limit it and but
limited in in importantly two most
important aspects I guess you would say
in the game player safety so that a sky
judge not somebody sitting in the replay
booth not the replay official who has
enough to do anyways just an eighth
official in the booth with a guy to help
him run the video and let him get
involved in all player safety issues
throughout the course of the game and
then let him get involved in pass
interference in the last five minutes of
the fourth quarter that's what it was in
the AAF and to me makes perfect sense
player safety if you call if the
officials on the field call a hit on a
defenseless receiver because they said
there was helmet contact but the video
shows that they're not that it's not
then the sky judge could fall down and
pick it up vice versa if he doesn't call
it but it is clear helmet to helmet
contact and about he can put it on let's
focus on what the league feels is the
most important thing going forward with
the league which is player safety so
let's utilize the sky judge
the eighth official much like the field
judge the back judge and the in the side
judge let's utilize him for player
safety and then let him get involved in
passive experience in my last five
minutes of the fourth quarter I think
it's simple I think bill put together a
good plan and and I think it could
easily work here and I you know I
understand Troy Benson saying that they
don't have the pipeline of you know of
people to where do you get these people
I think the other simple plan is just
make him a part of the crew an official
he comes out of the college ranks like
everybody else and guess what the deep
officials rotate so you you'll be in
that position this guy judge positions
every third game and into me then that
college guy gets experience both on the
field and in the booth and and and I
just think it's it's the one concept
rich in my opinion that's out there that
if you're really trying to change
officiating if you're really trying to
make officiating better and you're
really trying to get more calls right
forget about the offside or lined up in
the neutral zone or delay a game player
safety pass interference let's go it'll
work if you want to expand later try to
expand later and then how how does for
those who might not have seen the AAF
Mike how does it work from because for
me you know my issue always is a flag
that you don't see flying in when you're
watching it and you know the the the
crew in the truck doesn't light up the
yellow flag rectangle in a manner that
you you see or you know quickly enough
or you're in the stands you're at a game
and you don't see the flag thrown
certainly so how are you an in the
stands no a flag has been thrown how
will we know when a sky judge chimes in
and if it's late that might really rile
up a lot of people and understand
getting it right is better than then not
and that would really rile people up I'm
just concerned about the actual
mechanics of it and how that would fail
the process I mean let me just say let
me just say this but you know I think
that the game is
through so many changes and it looks so
different and people get used to it and
I think people would get used to this
also and I'd have to say that the the
call that is either made by the sky
judge or picked up by the sky judge will
be obvious it's not something you would
hope that would be incorrectly put on or
incorrectly reversed but you know I have
to tell you it was interesting I went
back and looked at the championship game
the Broncos at the Chiefs
in 1997 that was my last game and a
horrible call that I made in that game
or failed to me and I watched the whole
game for the first time about three
weeks ago and you know I have to say
after watching a three-hour football
game without instant replay my god it
was a thing of beauty I mean and in the
interruption that have come into the
game now with instant replay all of the
stops whether it's initiated by the the
replay official himself or if it's a
call that a coach challenges there's so
many stops but we've gotten used to it
and we're not going to go back and I
think Tinley since we're using
technology and there are already college
conferences they're all using the you
know the power five conferences all
using eight officials let's just take
the step and see if it works look I
think it's got a hell of a lot better
chance of working than the pass
interference screw up last year making
that reviewable I think this is it's
worth the shot rich it'll look different
and the flag will be delayed but the
referee will make the announcement after
input from the sky judge there was pass
interference on the play number 23
defense it's first and ten at the
15-yard line move on goal and you know
the next day probably nothing will be
mentioned in the newspaper or the
talk-show host because it'll become a
normal part of the game few more minutes
left with Mike Pereira as he's fishing
right here on the Rich Eisen show I'll
just give you the floor that I'm a
ultimate question about pass
interference no longer being a
reviewable play that there was a 0.0
full blue tarski shot of that thing
being made perm
as the as the rule mandated that they
were gonna try it for one year and then
revisit it for permanence just like
instant replay the year that I started
on NFL Network at that owners meeting
and at the breakers in Florida so why
why did it fail Mike was it doomed from
the start
walk me through that Louis 32 zip after
one week of the season last year quite
frankly in the opinion of coaches and
everybody that it wasn't going to work
and look it's simple
I mean you there's no way there's
absolutely no way that you can make a a
play a judgment call like replay and
attach to different standards to it so
you have you want to called one way on
the field but then if it's get
challenged or reviewed then you want to
call it a different way in replay so
it's pass interference that either is or
isn't on the field but when it went to
the replay booth and pour out River on
then it was like yeah it's pass
interference but is it big enough is it
big enough for us to call and replay is
it big enough to what in the compare to
what happened in New Orleans it's it's
senseless it was senseless and it wasn't
fair to the poor out rerun and if you
want to make it work like under the sky
judge position yes when you get into the
last five minutes
it is either interference or it's not
when replay shows that the contact is
early
forget about it's just a little bit
early but it's early then it's
interference so use one standard you use
one standard and then to me it has a
chance but you know I would also really
make it be the into the game the last
five minutes because in that in that
championship game in New Orleans there
was a big mess in the first quarter
anybody talking about that no because it
was the first quarter it's at the end of
the game when it has the impact so I do
think it can work if you use the same
stance and again when you said just to
wrap this up go full circle here you
said at the beginning when something is
withdrawn it's dead you just meant for
the current season tabled means that it
could actually mean it could actually
come into being for the upcoming season
withdrawn means it just needs to be
starting from scratch the next year
exactly okay
do you think that there's a shot at ask
okay you sound very imeem you saw a
bullish on the sky Judge Mike certainly
ma'am I am this game is getting harder
and harder to appreciate and the
officials themselves might not you know
say well we don't want it well I know
they say that a lot but the fact is this
game the players are getting faster in
Morse I mean it is a very tough game to
officiate and who gets all the criticism
the official so give them a tool to get
the major calls right and use another
official don't use instant replay
don't use the replay officials let's
just let's just hand them an aid a
different aid so that they can basically
their overall performance including
their eighth official this guy judge
really improved on a man did it ask you
before you hang up what was the the call
that you blew or you didn't make from
years ago oh my god simple it was my one
and only playoff game actually because I
went into the office after my second
year but the most the simplest illegal
contact called in the world a down and
out from Academy they actually ran out
and up and he got chucked at ten yards
and Elway still in the pocket and and
I'm the side judge to make the call and
I froze I swallowed the olive I choked
whatever you want to call it you know it
was it was awful and I'll never forget
it
and Mike Shanahan still talks to me
about that no come on now no but I did
come on oh he does he does and and you
know here's the deal at the end of the
game toward the end game in the fourth
quarter on a fourth down pass into the
inseong tony gonzalez went up and was
hit and he landed in bounds out of
bounds it was so tough was it a force
that was it not what hit first out of
bounds and of course it fell on my
shoulders and so I ended up really
incomplete so they turned over the ball
and Denver won the game and actually was
right on that one and so I I remind
Micah bout right when and he tells me oh
yeah that's right that was the great
call and of course you know we won the
Super Bowl and then I always say well
then where's my damn ring I got that's
alright I should get a Super Bowl ring
for God
so if Shannon never to share along he's
got a long memory I was about to say so
when you were the head of NFL reps and
he's coming at you about something that
was current did he ever remind you that
you screwed that one up just like what
he was accused was growing up this time
Yeah right before you hung up yes he
would remind me of that take care of
yourself Mike go go go catch your fish
go you got to hope they keep by and
that's Mike Pereira hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here